cimetière dégagé
je dis pas plus vous nous parler de ce
pas vraiment un gadget ben c'est la
linotype oui et je sais que vous pensez
pas que c'est un gage en attendant on
n'avait pas ça dans nos sous sols mais
quand vous regardez ça fonctionner cette
machine du diable vous pouvez pas le
diable simplement énorme et vous pouvez
pas en venir à une autre conclusion que
c'est le plus formidable gadget que vous
aurez jamais vu donc c'est vrai parce
que c'est en quelque sorte une horloge
d'impression au nom en haut comme on a
étendu la définition du cadre
aujourd'hui okc vous me le permettrais
parce que il ya des mécanismes
électrique là dedans yeux du métal fondu
c'est plein de cliquetis partout il ya
des roues dentées sa paire me permettait
donc d'imprimer une ligne de texte sur
un bloc de plans s'il ya quelques années
de ça parce que ça fait déjà un bout
taxes et disparus mais il fallait taper
le texte sur un clavier ça c'est le
travail de gilles et d'authie piste ça
faisait tomber des matrices de cuivre
dans un magasin et ses matrices ça
semblait ensuite en lien et donc ça la
ligne ça devenait un moule qui se
plaçait devant une chambre de couler où
je trouvais un alliage de plomb d'étain
et d'antimoine qui était en fusion et
l'a donc qu'il s'était injecté sous
pression sur les matrices je vous le
rappelle qui était le moule sa fille ges
a constitué des lignes bloc et qui était
distribué ou linotypiste en attente donc
d'être assemblés des faits d'impression
et pendant ce temps-là lee matrix elle
était retournée au magasin et était
prête à être de nouveau utilisées
c'était assez compliqué merci c'est une
machine je vous le disais tout à l'heure
le c'est hallucinant avoir fonctionné ça
a été inventé aux états unis par un
immigrant allemand
morgenthaler pas l'autre pas dû
connaître un autre qui a révolutionné
les primaires et les médias parce
qu'avant la linotype il faut savoir que
les journaux de partout sur la planète
il ne pouvait pas avoir plus que 8 h
parce que c'était trop long a semblé
lettre par lettre et c'est à l'aide de
cette machine va donc on a imprimé les
journaux les magazines
de la fin du 19e siècle jusqu'aux années
70 aujourd'hui c'est fini mais il reste
dense y est oui nautile piste et c'était
du chef blogueurs du journal de montréal
michel dumais que vous connaissez jeunes
moins sûr qu'ils travaillaient sur une
île au type dans l'imprimerie de son
père on en a parlé ensemble ce matin
lorsqu'on regarde aujourd'hui une
linotype lorsqu'on pense aux arts
exemple à nos enfants on se dit mais
qu'est ce que c'est cette machine là et
il faut dire que c'était dans son temps
au début du xxème siècle une machine
extrêmement
complexe lorsqu'on faisait l'entretien
sur 10 nautiques pour faisait de la
mécanique
cet outil a complètement changé la
productivité dans le domaine de
l'impression à savoir souvenez-vous
autrefois ce qu'on avait c'était des
petits caractères que l'on prenait un
parent
et puis qu'on a semblé on assemblait des
mots ainsi or l'arrivée de la linotype
ça a été une machine qui avec un clavier
nous permettait donc de taper de pouvoir
composer des phrases rapidement et en
actionnant un levier eh bien on pouvait
produire des plaques de plomb ce qu'on
avait des lignes de plomb et très
rapidement construire une page donc les
sort qu'ont connu les grands quotidiens
papier et bien c'est dû en grande partie
ou si à l'arrivée de la linotype que
complètement changé dans cette
productivité dans le domaine des médias
ça me manque énormément parce qu'on
devait se concentrer on devait vraiment
tout planifié tout prévoir avant de
commencer à travailler on pouvait et on
devait en quelqu'un prendre son temps
aussi parce que c'était trop facile de
se tromper de recommencer et pas
question pour moi de nier la modernité
aujourd'hui les motiver les outils
auxquelles nous avons accès mais un peu
comme lorsqu'on parle du livre et on dit
ouais c'est bien le niveau électronique
meilleur quelque chose dans le livre
papier il se couche tactile et bien
c'est un peu ça aussi
aujourd'hui le monde de l'infographie
c'est un monde complètement des
virtualisés alors que là on travaillait
avec des outils bien réel et ce n'était
pas des pitchs et des lignes de pixels
mais bien des lignes de plomb avec
lesquels on travaillait s'installer à au
marbre et puis monter sa page et puis
voir le résultat une fois qu'on mettait
ça ensuite dans les braises
il y avait toujours ce rituel à chaque
matin la première chose je me dirigeais
vers la linotype alors je mettais le
courant parce que c'était du courant
électrique et ont commencé à faire
fondre les bars de plomb et d'antimoine
chamakh et on hamm est et on n'a juste
pas de nouvelles on a laissé faire les
petits cafés on allait voir un peu
c'était quoi bon les bons de commande
pour la journée des gens arrivés et ont
discuté il y avait toujours un bonheur
un vrai plaisir à travailler je me suis
jamais ennuyé
jamais jamais jamais alors que des fois
je vous fais une confidence des fois
j'ai l'impression m'enquiquiner
joyeusement face à un écran jamais j'ai
expérimenté sa façon des odeurs des
gestes des textures qui n'existe plus
voilà
c'est vrai que quand on est devant un
écran c'est un peu froid mais quand il y
avait quelque chose c'était différent je
suis un pas définitif des machines avec
du papier perforé ça m'en souvienne
comme un coq d'occasions d'aller dans
des voyages à l'étranger de savoir
comment ces l'analogique en même temps
ça plante raja mais non c'est ça est-ce
qu'on peut encore en voir je n'ai que
des lignes hautes fonctions dans
certains musées c'est le cas mais vous
vous en doutez bien avec la révolution
informatique de suivi la plupart sont
allés à la ferraille mais il faut que je
vous recommande un documentaire intitulé
tout simplement
linotype qui est paru assez récemment je
crois que c'est 2012 ne serait ce que
pour voir ces machines ne fonctionnent
et de voir aussi quels étaient les
artisans qui s'activait justement
là-dessus et on voit vraiment que ce
sont des gens de lettres et où on envoie
quelques zones qui vont dire un mois ça
me revient à l'esprit le on en parle
mais qui disait si votre bouche vous
empêche empêche vous m travailler fermez
votre bouche parce que le vrai de la
marque ça se fait avec lui mais
justement il et on va vous mettre un
lien sur twitter de la bande annonce de
ce documentaire là il est sur itunes et
on y apprend des tas de choses notamment
que je vous parlais qu'ils étaient des
gens l'est de laiterie corriger parfois
les journalistes quand les erreurs se
glissait dans les textes ça pas l'air de
vous surprendre beaucoup annoncé jacques
ségéla doit cesser cet été s'est classé
que ça vient du du temps où les où les
gens des employés d'imprimeries était à
peu près des souhaits ce qu'ils savaient
lire écrire mais les idéaux types et
c'était des gens qui savaient très bien
ce qu'ils faisaient moi j'ai jamais
travaillé dans un journal qui en
utilisent est d'accord mais à l'époque
où j'étais jeune journaliste certains
journaux d'après-midi le toronto star
entre autres avait encore pour ça une
est encore fait à la ligne au type et je
me souviens dans des
breaking news à des moments où les ou
une nouvelle arrive sur le chat que le
joindre au dos tant qu'athlète
directement du nautilys pour que sortir
dans la rue tout de suite et il pouvait
changer la une sur le choc sur le champ
ça se et puis plus aux mines
d'ordinateurs plus ils ont réussi à ce
que on comprenne plus de temples d'être
là l'heure de tombée depuis le début de
la versys natale à saint ce voyage
ehlinger est beaucoup faire dix ans
michel roy